three of the big public january 6 select
committee hearings have occurred and one
of the big questions people are asking
amidst all of this
is
is there any chance trump will be held
legally responsible for the actions he
took namely his attempt to overturn a
free and fair election and keep himself
in power i covered the story that we're
about to talk about on my own show
you can find it by just searching luke
beasley on youtube or if you're watching
this on youtube or listening to the
podcast it will be in the description so
you just click a link it will take you
there
or you can just like i said search my
name be this on youtube and then david
likely also covered this when it came
out but i thought it'd be really
interesting to look at in the context of
these hearings and all the revelations
that have come out to take another look
at this so quote a former federal
prosecutor who served for more than 24
years in the district of columbia's u.s
attorney's office says donald trump
could be arrested or indicted on just
the evidence included in monday's
bombshell legal ruling by u.s district
court judge david o'carter so now
describes that legal ruling judge
carter's findings by a preponderance of
the evidence which says more likely than
not that trump committed felony offenses
is a higher evident jury standard than
the one needed to arrest and indict
trump for his crimes which requires only
probable cause
judge carter on monday wrote based on
the evidence the court finds it's more
likely than not that president trump
corruptly attempted to obstruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
21. in response legal experts are
calling his ruling striking massive
monumental and historic
so this was a ruling about john eastman
whether or not he had to
turn over documents to the january 6th
committee but as you saw in there this
judge is saying it's likely there's
enough evidence to indict trump on
criminal charges that's insane
but obviously the big question is is it
likely
okay we can talk about wow he should be
but is this actually something that's
going to happen
and at this point i think david pakman's
assessment that we probably shouldn't be
expecting to see trump do the perp walk
is still correct unfortunately in the
country we live in
powerful people are rarely held
accountable to this extent and actually
there's some other reasons for why
merrick garland might be timid and
they're legitimate reasons i don't think
they're enough for him not to go through
with it but i read this op-ed by the new
york times that made a case for why it
wouldn't be so crazy for merrick garland
to um
be really you know
soft
and uh timid on this particular issue
and
while i think it's it's it's wrong in
its assessment like
regardless of the backlash regardless of
the political claims that will be made
we should follow rule of law if trump
committed crimes he needs to be held
criminally responsible but i do
understand how scary and wild it is to
think about the aftermath of something
like this if trump was indicted
the riots the insane mayhem that would
happen i mean that is something to be
feared for sure
um
but that can't scare us away from doing
what is right which is holding trump
accountable if he committed crimes of
course i'm not a legal expert
i would want the legal experts of course
to
analyze and see not just what trump did
but compared to the law
how did he clearly break it and if he
did he needs to be held
responsible
it's also really horrible to think about
the potential where um
the potential world where trump is
unsuccessfully
prosecuted and for the rest of time he's
just so bolstered in his claims that
this is also political and he's been
correct the whole time that this was all
witch hunt
don't like thinking about that
hypothetical so i think behind the
scenes merrick garland needs to make a
really strong case or see if he can make
based on the evidence a really strong
case and if he can't don't pursue it but
if there is a clear
laws he violated
actions he took
evidence to prove it then he needs to go
through with it maybe he you know
appoints a special prosecutor to do that
process
but beforehand he needs to see if
there's
such clear hard evidence that this would
be an undeniable case to prove
and you honestly wish that we would be
in a country where people could look at
this evidence and look
at the actions that trump took and
change their mind you know like all of
these people on the right
i wish they would just watch the january
6 hearings with an open mind and not
think this is all fake news
because a lot of this is so clear what
trump did and if they believed he did
what he did you would hope they would no
longer want to support him i don't know
maybe they're also just not for
democracy but hopefully you believe the
only reason that they support this
anti-democratic behavior is because they
think it's saving the democracy because
it was stolen from trump right
just to kind of close it is interesting
a majority of americans do support
indicting trump actually
but it's
54 so it's not like the whole country or
anything the survey found that 54
percent of respondents backed the idea
of the department of justice indicting
the foreign president over the capital
right compared to 37 percent who oppose
the suggestion
obviously and i'll say this many times
it needs to come down to the evidence
can the doj make an undeniable case that
trump violated certain laws here they
are and here's the evidence of those
violations and if they can then he
should absolutely be prosecuted
let me know in the comments what you
guys think i'm super curious to hear
likely unlikely give me your assessment
definitely in the comments thank you so
much to the dave hackman show for having
me guest host today um you can check out
my channel if you're watching on youtube
or listening the podcast just by going
to the description and click clicking
the link it'll take you to my channel or
if you're coming from another place just
search luke beasley on youtube or luke
beasley on any podcast listening
platform and you should be able to find
my show
be well everybody